a health care professional can measure  your blood pressure to find out if you  have high blood pressure this video will  help you understand what the numbers in  your blood pressure mean  your blood pressure can be measured with  a blood pressure cuff called a  sphygmomanometer  when your heart beats the pressure of  blood on the walls of your arteries is  called systolic pressure  when your heart relaxes between beats  pressure on the artery wall is called  diastolic pressure  your blood pressure may change  throughout the day however it should  normally be less than 124 systolic  pressure and four diastolic pressure it  should normally be less than 80  if your systolic pressure frequently  stays above 140 or your diastolic  pressure frequently stays above 90 you  have high blood pressure  your specific goals may vary depending  on your health situation ask your doctor  what your blood pressure goals should be